il a longtemps minimisé la maladie mais
jaillir ball sonar au prend quand même
ses précautions
après avoir annoncé à cnn brésil qu'ils
présentaient des symptômes du
coronavirus le président brésilien s'est
soumis à un test dont les résultats
seront révélés aujourd'hui s'il reste
sceptique au sujet de la pandémie
le chef d'état s'est montré avec un
masque sur le visage chose rare depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire
j'évite de m'approcher des gens parce
que je sors de l'hôpital le poumon est
propre d'accord je vais faire un test de
co vide dans un petit moment mais tout
va bien
quelques heures avant cette intervention
d'hier ball sonar a opposé son veto à
deux articles de la loi sur
l'utilisation des masques dans les lieux
publics
un assouplissement qui concerne
notamment les prisons surpeuplées du
pays où il n'est donc plus obligatoire
même les commerces n'auront pas à
afficher des panneaux informatifs sur
l'utilisation du masque un
assouplissement qui a lieu en même temps
que la réouverture des bars restaurants
et salons de beauté à sao paulo capitale
économique du pays dans une nouvelle
étape de déconfinement la ville sans une
quarantaine qui a duré une centaine de
jours les commerces pourront ouvrir
quotidiennement durant six heures
seulement à 40 % de leur capacité
d'accueil une réouverture attendue même
si commerçants et clients doivent
s'adapter je meurs vraiment envie de
sortir
ça vous donne un sentiment de liberté
vous savez être à la maison pendant
trois mois sans sortir pour quoi que ce
soit et difficile la plupart des clients
tu travailles tu es domicile la plupart
d'entre eux travaillent encore à
domicile et en raison des horaires
réduits
ce n'est pas bon pour nous non plus car
on s'occupe des clients la nuit on
travaillait de 9 à 7 heures avant et
maintenant nous sommes ici de 11 à 4
heures donc c'est un peu difficile
si le pays se dé confine la pandémie est
toujours présente en termes de
contamination et deux décès le brésil
est toujours le deuxième pays le plus
touché au monde derrière les etats unis